if you're going to get honest get honest
now we're not going to email it to them
just write it
and i think that that's
where they start to unlock
what's the inciting incident in your
book it would be
waking up from the dream
absolutely
and sitting in my living room and really
thinking
oh
i know
and then
uh what do i do now
that's the inciting incident
there's
a whole journey that comes from that and
and most people like clients that i work
with in their books
it's usually that
that one t it's not always like the most
exciting moment necessarily it's that
stop that inside moment where you know
something's gonna change forever
and it did
when you went to sleep the night before
had you watched a movie did something
happen do you think triggered it or no
it was just
this time
why did you procrastinate writing for so
long i know you had this realization but
didn't weren't there other things you
were putting off yeah i mean i think
that i had to go through a lot of
different experiences so that i could
know what to write about
so if i had just started writing right
away from the dream and i was i was
journaling everything so i had a lot of
good material
but i hadn't lived enough yet to really
see the difference right so like
i had to be a recovered so i had to be a
survivor for a little while before i
felt like i could really look
at what i had slighted myself in in
living
to write about what i could potentially
have and my second book which is written
and it's sitting on my laptop is all
about the next steps which is you've put
in a bunch of years as a survivor you've
seen the change and you're ready to
leave behind
that past of how you used to live and
you're ready to kind of now take this
new you into another level of your life
but i am procrastinating on it
i've decided i want to write another
book that's a lot more fun so
that can happen sometimes and get
distracted but i do believe everything
is in the right time
so um i know that my first book got
published so i know that another one
will
and i've actually
taken that book down the first memoir
i took the rights back from the
publisher in december i don't feel like
the service was done that it deserves
people read it and they go this is like
the most amazing book i've ever read on
abuse
this should be a worldwide book and the
publisher did not do a good job so
um and neither did i frankly because
today you have to be behind your book
100 you can't rely on a publisher at all
and so i've taken the book rights back
i'm actually doing a second edition on
it i'm going to rename it and i'm going
to put it out under my own publishing
label
why rename it
kicking abuse in the ass was a very sort
of
yeah
kind of title right
and i want it to reach more people so
now i'm going to call it awoken
okay
are you do you think the title might
scare certain people
uh
i i want to go more direct i think what
i've learned with my clients and helping
them come up with book titles and and
chapter headings
there's like there's a there's a fine
line between clever
and kind of not
really telling people what you're going
to do for them in the book like kicking
abuse in the ass
it wasn't really what i was doing in the
book 100
it wasn't like i was going in there and
slaying it i was really being reflective
why do you think most writers
procrastinate
oh a whole i could give you the longest
list i hear i've heard everything
from i'm afraid of being famous
what will i do with all my time when i'm
famous how am i going to take care
i don't want to upset my family members
i don't know if i can finish something
i've started so they don't even start
uh i'm not i don't have a writing degree
like i don't have like a you know
i'm not a graduate of the iowa state
writing you know writing conference so
why bother
um a lot of a lot of reasons a lot of
reasons i can't find time on my schedule
i don't understand what kind of support
i need i don't know what kind of
structure there should be
a million reasons
you had talked about you were looking to
maybe one day direct
uh write and direct as the new kim
what what you saw as the new kim do you
think people don't know
what the new self would be as this
author if that like you've talked about
this fear of being famous whatever but
also too they'd be taking on this new
persona
that maybe they'd be leaving victimhood
or whatever behind and now
can you talk about that oh yeah the new
persona and how you
transformed into that
i love that this question is
such a beautiful question because it
comes up actually more
in the class i run called own your
authorship
where it's sort of that chasm between
like they have the desire to tell their
story but the yes feels like kind of far
you know
and people come in and they they take
the class and they're like a little bit
like
who are you and who do you you know a
little bit
like not chip on their shoulder but you
know let's see what you got you know
and i just work them till you know we
turn we do a prompt that's called i hate
you because
and
many people write about themselves
and then i make them go back and write
it about someone else and they go well i
don't want to hate somebody else i go
well you know you do
so why don't you tell us about it like
if you're going to get honest get honest
now we're not going to email it to them
just write it and i think that that's um
where they start to unlock and they
start to see themselves and and start to
be okay and then they just really like
you see a shift immediately where
there's they're realizing wait a minute
like i have a story to tell and then we
do you know come find a picture of
yourself in your 20s
some groups i'll do little kids like
i'll kind of intuitively gauge the group
i can tell very early on
what i need to do with people i'm very
intuitive that way
and
from that writing about where they came
from you just see them start to just
like light up and then we talk about the
author persona and what is your author
persona like who would you be if you
were like a successful author what does
that look like would you have your own
jet
are you doing a book tour worldwide or
is this where you make all your income
and you see a lot of them like well i
don't know i mean is that well
we're not saying that's going to happen
or not happen i just want you to write
about it you know
and so a lot of the resistance is the
um
it's almost like they feel like
they're saying something that's not true
by writing about it
even though it's a dream they have
so if you can get them to write about
the dream then the dream suddenly
doesn't seem so far-fetched
what do you think your biggest
resistance was to writing i think for me
a lot of it was time i was
single parenting
trying to build a business
and
i literally did not have any time i also
did not hire a coach
which i should have done when i finally
hired an editor everything moved really
fast because i was ready
but i think i just
i i you know i didn't take my own
medicine you know i didn't bring in
someone i was telling everybody that
were my clients how important it is to
be coachable and i wasn't co being
coached so i'd say my resistance was i
didn't think that
i was worthy of
exactly what i tell my clients to
believe they're worthy of
how do you know you have the right coach
so i'm sure there's a gazillion coaches
editors out there
you know there's not a lot of book
coaches um
that
necessarily do a white glove service i
don't hear about a lot of them i hear
about you know editors that might edit
your book over 90 days or um
and i'm doing more of like a deep dive
into like the whole
purview of the person like what do you
want to what does this book mean to you
like what do you want to be with this
book like
i often help people come up with
um
trademarkable systems or
uh
business ideas or mantras that they can
actually then claim as their own through
the writing of the book that they
couldn't see before i'll be like that's
brilliant nobody else is doing that and
they'll be like oh my god yeah
so i'm not sure that that's so much of
just an editor i think that is
definitely more of a coach because i'm
seeing the human potential
in that person
through what they're sharing with me
about who they are
and then we happen to be writing a book
through it all
so is this someone who already has a
first draft finish
i don't take people typically on that
have a first draft because then we'd
have to break it all up and then i'm
just putting glue on something that's
probably broken so i like to work with
people from the very very start
so if i call you and say or email you
and say i would like to write about
my life
i don't even have an outline i'm just
telling you this is my desire and we're
going to go from there and structure it
together yep wow yeah that's that's my
favorite way to work because we really
just
start from this from scratch you know we
do the outline together and then we go
through
um eight months of work
what are some of the first questions you
asked someone
it really depends on the people i mean i
don't have a formula
more than
outline day first draft second draft
third draft get the book published
i ask them a lot of questions before i
do the outline day with them and kind of
ask them about
you know tell me about three amazing
moments in your life you know
write to me about what you think about
yourself what were some of your greatest
accomplishments
um if they've told me a little bit about
uh something that happened in their life
or why they became a coach or
why they've been a binge eater or you
know what it was like in the navy i'll
say give me a couple scenes on that
because from that i can sort of get a
tone
of what it would be and then and a lot
of that is movie business work you know
kind of seeing what the scenes are
and then wrapping around the scenes a
narrative for the book
do you ever ask them the why
yeah we do that knowing your authorship
we work out the why
generally because people
that are not ready to write a book
the reason is because they're not
confident in their why
so that's why i have them take the class
people that come to be ready to be a
private client they're pretty rock
they've got a really good why it might
be a little bit smaller than they think
like i'll find a bigger why
but generally they come in with like
this is what i'm writing about and i
don't have to like work it
so these aren't wishy-washy people on
the fence they're they're like there's
no people that do my one year now
there's not a lot of convincing
i like to say like if someone comes to
me for a one year they're usually like
there's no cell
they're just in
but if i'm on the phone with someone for
a really long time then
generally they're not going to be a
client right away
you